[Music]
after bon week so the guards came along
and took Jake and uh Choi happened
pretty rapidly
there's no tearful goodbyes or anything
it was just dude okay bye see you see it
I had no idea where they were going and
I had no idea really what reason they
had for going off and I was being left
behind
I very much knew that I was alone and I
wasn't any part of any group there and I
was gonna live by myself or I was gonna
die by myself at that point there was a
very high chance I was gonna die in that
prison
[Music]
I was transferred over into Pannell
Garcia Moreno which is their equivalent
of a Supermax they had the highest
security prisoners there certainly it
was a step up made me very nervous
the prison way out was for pabbie ohms
or wings a B&B and Papillon D were more
for the murderers and rapists and
kidnappers luckily I saved it to go over
in the patio C which was mainly for
international prisoners and drug
traffickers
for anybody who came in there especially
any foreigner especially anybody who'd
never been in that kind of experience
before it was a very intimidating
experience and I knew I was gonna be
there for a while how long I did note
[Music]
laughter a couple months I was called
down to the infirmary Dutch had been
able to spread a little bit of money
around and was able to come over to the
prison
[Music]
so I came down and talked to him and we
talked about his case slub dinner
hey Dutch are you bearing up in there
that's a great man you got to get me the
hell out of here fast
see that's what I want to talk to you
about Dutch because he wasn't caught
with drugs had a reasonable chance to
get away free I can walk
bunny Jew play ball you're talking about
he told me what he wanted was that I was
going to be the intellectual author of
the crime that was your idea then I was
going to make it explicit that I was
guilty guilty guilty and he was innocent
innocent innocent can't believe this we
talk it's not a big deal for you to help
me out here
all right you're going to are you gonna
have a problem if I didn't he was going
to spend a couple of hundred dollars to
have me murdered
[Music]
don't make me have you murdered then did
you know that I can and you know that I
weird so when he said those things to me
I took them to be a very real threat
because for a couple hundred dollars it
was very much possible to do just that
give a nice day and that's basically
what it came down to